and the other thing is the Bernie put
the rogue and clip out and a lot of
people flipped out you're gonna lose
here's the deal you're gonna lose again
you want to lose you fetishize being a
loser and you want to lose you're
putting people through these purity
tests it's gonna it's gonna bite you
rogon is such an asset to have and
whether I don't even think it's fair by
the way I would be like it's not fair to
put out a clip of someone as an official
endorsement right if they haven't
officially endorsed you I don't know
that they had a conversation which or
not but my whole thing is like to get
angry yeah about it is so [ __ ]
childish and I mean I don't know how
more progressive that was the over the
years a bunch of you know Roman stuff
and like I don't know how much more
progressive he can be they want him to
cut his dick off yeah I mean they want
him to transition he could be more
progressive and cut his dick off there
and became a woman
they're pretty could be what they're
looking for they want him to saw his
[ __ ] off and shove it and Barry Rice's
throat and then and then that's how he
could be more progressive okay he takes
his dick off and then he throws it and
Barry Weiss's face it goes free
Palestine and then it would be okay to
endorse Bernie Sanders he's had on Abby
Martin Kyle kuklinski Cornel West Bernie
Sanders David Pakman he talked to Matt
Taibbi in his three to four-hour
conversations about things like you know
prison industrial complex Israel and
Palestine race inequality all of those
things and you turn on CNN they've got
Richard Spencer stormy Daniels right
Rachel Maddow is [ __ ] talking about
Putin hiding in a closet and she goes
has dinner with Roger Ailes and she
probably puts on a strap-on and [ __ ]
them so let's get real Rachel Maddow and
Roger Ailes have dinner together it's
all fake here the conversation was my
low vice you know talks to [ __ ] what
was it Cantwell yeah [ __ ] at me for
it right Rachel Maddow it was like close
with Roger Ailes yeah so it's you
professional Rhett it doesn't stop
and that's why people that are like
online or people that get their news
from these I love my dad but here's what
happened to my father's brain it's been
rotted because he's gotten his news from
people like chris matthews and chris
matthews when the whole apps anything
happened chris matthews who is a irish
fat blowhard okay who does nothing but
parrot the party line of anything that's
going on loves washington loves powerful
people is the opposite of a journalist
is it looks like a hunk of Irish soda
bread it's not he's nowhere near Tim
Russert even had some Russert not a few
tip of money to press right no no
someone else I don't think Chris
Matthews no Chris Matthews owes that
kind of hardball is like huh he was
parodied constantly yeah with good
reason when the whole epstein thing
happened this was Chris Matthews hot
tank okay by the way by the way not only
should the Irish not be allowed to speak
publicly they should be chained at all
times to do their physical job okay
Christmas Chris Matthews Chris mean uh
if they just don't lift let's be I'm
sick of line most Irish people excluding
me most Irish people just are not
supposed to think they're supposed to
emote they're supposed to sing they're
supposed to dance and they're supposed
to tell tales but they're not supposed
to like break it down so this was Chris
Matthews response when the FCC things
happened he goes you know a lot of these
politicians end up take because they
egos they become friends with these
nefarious characters because they don't
have a lot of money so they need to fly
places because they're politicians they
need to go to places so they end up
forming relationships with these you
know nefarious characters he's dark and
they don't know what's going on they
don't know how can they know we're gonna
wait in the airport for 10 minutes yeah
so Bill and Hillary Clinton can't afford
to go anywhere should be less tough land
where do they all need to go the Virgin
Islands where are they going they got
thing I think in like a million dollar
speaking fee somewhere yeah
but again imagine think of the people
who got their news from that system for
years because even the articles written
about Epstein from the mainstream press
like yeah that's a little fishy right
now the flip side of that is if you go
online you know you know it's we we all
know what online is it's just a [ __ ]
you know it's completely no it's free
for all with a guy and you know goat
horns just you know sacrificing the
Baphomet it's like there's no there's no
moderation
there's no moderation but in this case
this is the one case where they're
mostly right yeah but they're mostly
right yeah it's but that's the real
problem the real problem is that our
parents got their news and that's where
we are the country we do you eat poison
you get your news from people that
literally should not be allowed to speak
publicly who are just handed talking
points less it should get your news from
these people you eat it Wendy's you
drink you get prescribed all these drugs
and then at the end of everything it's
like yeah there's nothing left
nothing's left it's all gone and then
you have to deal with all these massive
problems 40% of the labor force is gonna
be automated and like our parents just
want to play golf and get a condo they
don't they're like witty what they're
like who gives a [ __ ] what do you mean
40% of Labor for good do like that
sounds nice like you tell people that
you tell people that are older than I
think a 40% of Labor was gonna be
alright they're like you kids have it so
easy you have no idea how lucky you are
you know you're gonna have hate waiting
on lines in the carwash
you know the labor force they're just
it's they're gonna be what these kids
can have automated you know you know my
son told me Dave Vinny he said forty
percent of the labor force gonna be
robots they're gonna be sim pretty these
kids they're gonna be sitting pretty
these guys I mean can you believe how
lucky they are well that is on some
weird way if you actually look in the
marks time I Center a long toss copper
towel but you know Ray's become a fat
Marxist i'ma which is somehow living in
Brooklyn is somehow his journey to
become like this fat he went from a fat
libertarian to a fat Marxist because
they're too
you can go from libertarian you stay fat
but you go to either Marx or you go to
Nazi but you stay and I am I argue as
I'm sexy I argue if we can afford health
care and we can afford universal health
care you go we're just gonna do it [ __ ]
it I'm gonna March this I just don't
care what happens yeah that's a
difference I'm set I look I have no
investment in literally what happens
whatever a non mark system you should
read them or you know we talk if you
want to oppose them point is a bit the
idea of it is that as Das Kapital
balanced on his stomach and a public
there's a woman sitting next to him just
nursing her baby and your life lesson
that's okay you can let it out we're all
human beings here you can let it out
baby don't worry about it I know why
you're in the position you're in this
man wrote a whole book on it see what
happened there is some part of it worse
like if we're supposed to get to a point
where we can all just like relax and
achieve higher consciousness Marla told
me about this it's like fully automated
luxury communism which mom was telling
me he was saying it as a joke it made me
laugh or just everyone [ __ ] all day and
but money's fake I don't know so many
very funny little message is really
smart hey girlfriends going to canvass
with Bernie Sanders and [ __ ] it where
she going New Hampshire we're gonna go
we want to film ourselves canvassing for
Bernie Sanders in Beverly Hills yeah
just standing outside gates and
screaming I read all about yeah give him
back a little bit
have you thought excuse me sir have you
heard for me Santa
he's also Jewish don't you have enough
don't you